vuelve los ataques a kiev después de que
las tropas rusas se hicieran con el
control total de la ciudad de
severodonezk en el donbass en un
importante revés para ucrania este
domingo los misiles del kremlin
volvieron a alcanzar la capital hasta
cuatro explosiones detonaron en el
centro de quiebre las primeras horas de
la mañana en el que se convirtió en el
primer ataque después de semanas de
tensa calma donde pese a todo las
sirenas aéreas siguen sonando
periódicamente es
cuestión de que me preguntas por qué
atacan kiev la verdadera pregunta es por
qué atacan a ucrania no hay ninguna
razón es una guerra en la que mueren
miles y miles de civiles no entendemos
por qué
el ataque se produjo en infraestructuras
civiles en un distrito que alberga
universidades restaurantes y galerías de
arte botox strip sets sobre las 6 y 30
de la mañana hubo una gran explosión las
paredes y las ventanas temblaron hubo
cuatro explosiones con un intervalo de
cinco a diez segundos salimos a la calle
y vimos los daños en la casa y como la
gente estaba cuando fue ruth o doce
factores horrible he visto la
destrucción muchos pisos ya no existen
solo hay paredes vacías porque tan
pronto
los bombardeos regresan a kiev
simultáneamente al inicio del g7 en
alemania donde uno de los principales
temas de la cumbre es precisamente el
avance de la guerra en ucrania